police need your help finding a  13-year-old boy tonight kamani allen was  last seen last week near carrion nellis  police say kamani could be in severe  emotional distress and in need of  medical assistance his father talked to  8 news now hoping our viewers can help  find his son  if you see him just call me  call me reach out to me he's definitely  definitely a stress and we just want him  home we love you we care about you you  know we fight to get you home we do  everything we can to get you home and we  just want you to know that we love you  and  we miss you every single second that  you're not home with us  take another look here if you have seen  kamani please contact metro police at  their missing persons detail that number  on your screen is 702-828-2907